y Trozos de agua sucia caen al día en
esta quebrada aledaña a una pequeña
Urbanización a 30 kilómetros de la
capital panameña es parte del sistema
fluvial que termina en el océano
Pacífico en el lugar existe una planta
de tratamiento que nunca funcionó
[Música]
según Magda esta situación se repite en
otras 87 urbanizaciones cercanas al
lugar de la provincia de Panamá oeste
nos preocupa Pues que estamos
contaminando no solamente esa quebrada
estamos contaminando el río aguacate al
final y al final el mar y cuántos años
ya llevamos más de 12 años en esto
estas tuberías tener en el agua sucia de
las casas el lugar donde terminan es
este río que ha cambiado su aspecto en
las últimas décadas según Comenta
benigno vecino de lugar por más de 50
años
el río estaba bonito todo limpia aguas
limpias agua que se podía bañar todo el
mundo ya digo te apoyan hasta pescar lo
que quisiera por ahí camarones de todo y
eso pero qué va a medir el tiempo fue
avanzando
añadiéndose tantas
Barriada tanta más gente y más gente
creciendo la comunidad el pueblo la
población Así mismo Claro que todo eso
va llegando a dónde al solamente al río
es el único que hay Son miles de litros
de agua permanente que corren y terminan
afectando el ecosistema Marino
principalmente los corales Carolina que
forma parte de un equipo científico del
smithsonian Investiga el impacto de las
aguas servidas
no todas las zonas tienen corrientes que
puedan que hacer que estas aguas se
mezclen y se combinen con agua fresca
que no que te que tengan una baja
descarga de O sea que tenga pocos
nutrientes Entonces
si no es una zona que hay un gran
movimiento de agua ya sea por viento o
por corrientes o si es una Bahía
semicerrada estos estanca la
contaminación de las aguas son parte de
los 19 problemas ambientales directos
que ha identificado el Ministerio de
ambiente de Panamá en la actualidad se
ejecuta un proyecto de saneamiento de la
Bahía de Panamá que garantizaría su
limpieza total en 2050 para evitar que
la contaminación urbana llegue a los
océanos